[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
horrible incident yesterday that many of
you have no doubt already heard about a
29 year old man from Uzbekistan rented a
flatbed pickup truck painted as a home
depot truck it's believed that it was an
actual Home Depot rental truck at this
time in New York City actually rented it
in New Jersey drove over into New York
City and down the West Side Highway and
into pedestrians on West Street in lower
Manhattan now West Street at that part
of Manhattan is the name of the West
Side Highway which is also known as
route 9a in New York City and when you
think about the shape of Manhattan it's
sort of narrow and long north to south
on the east side of the island
you have the FDR which is the sort of
north-south highway that exists there on
the west side you have the West Side
Highway and there's this really nice
bike path and running path alongside the
West Side Highway I know it well when
the David Pakman show was in New York
City our office was not too far from
this part and that's where the truck
veered off and into the bike path and
started to run people over and the use
of a truck to run people over has been a
mode employed by the sort of neo jihadi
Isis umbrella term terrorists over the
last couple of years but if there was
any doubt as to the ideological
background of this individual he
reportedly shouted Allahu Akbar god is
great in Arabic according to multiple
witnesses including both civilians and
law-enforcement officials when he was
exiting his truck now he exited the
truck with some people are describing
them as fake guns IB they were real guns
but it was a paintball gun and a pellet
gun so they were not real in the sense
that they did not fire what we would
call full ammunition full power
ammunition they were they were able to
fire paintballs and pellets and then the
driver shot by police and arrested
brought into surgery at Bellevue
Hospital in New York City out of surgery
FBI saying earlier today that they've
already interviewed the individual not
willing to say anything about the
content of those interviews at those at
this time and by all likely assessments
is going to spend the rest of his life
in prison now as far as the victims
eight people were killed total and I
found out that five were from my home
country of Argentina it was actually a
group of five Argentinians
who came to the United States to New
York City to celebrate a 30th
anniversary of high school graduation so
as you would imagine people who
graduated high school thirty years ago
in their late 40s at this time another
report said that the sixth non-american
victim was a Belgian woman later the
report said that it was a German
individual I guess we're not a hundred
percent sure at this time or at least
I'm not a hundred percent sure and as
you can imagine Argentinean News which I
watch every day in the morning has been
covering this extensively I've been
receiving notices from the Argentinean
consulate in New York City they've been
working to be in touch with family
members of the five Argentinean deceased
individuals working to figure out how to
get the remains back to Argentina as
quickly as possible but in concert with
the wishes of the families and then
other than the eight killed also eleven
injured including two kids maybe 12
injured I've seen both numbers the kids
at least reportedly not seriously hurt
some of the adults very seriously hurt
and now the the fallout of this
politically starts to happen and Donald
Trump using this in a totally sort of
confusing way in a disappointing way in
a disjointed and confused way putting
out a couple of tweets about this
incident starting first by saying and
see if you can understand what what he's
saying here we must not allow my sis to
return or enter our country after
defeating them in the Middle East and
elsewhere enough so right away this is
an attempt to brag about his so-called
defeat of Isis which by the way is no
big thing to brag about I've been saying
for years at this point that more than
likely within two years within 18 to 24
months Isis in terms of its stronghold
in the Middle East is going to be
effectively destroyed whether it's Trump
Obama Ted Cruz Hillary whoever it is
that's in power that's the direction
things have been going but the more
difficult thing is going to be to root
out these individual attacks around the
sort of under the umbrella of Isis
ideology and it's also fine to say well
we're not going to let bad people people
who want to do damage and bad things to
the u.s. into the country but remember
that this is an individual who came to
the United States legally from
Uzbekistan and Uzbekistan is not on
Trump's or anybody else's travel ban
list nor have I heard anyone even
suggest that whose beqaa stands should
be on the list so right away it's this
it's an attempt to politicize from
Donald Trump without it actually being
totally clear that he even understands
what's going on and then sadly in the
midst of all this Donald Trump putting
out another tweet about visas saying the
terrorists came into our country through
what's called the diversity Visa Lottery
program a Chuck Schumer beauty I want
merit-based and then also tweeting about
vetting I have just ordered homeland
security to step up our already extreme
vetting program being politically
correct it's fine but not for this
so immediately using the tragedy to try
to score confused and weird political
points and I've been clear when there's
a mass shooting that's a good time to
talk about mass shootings and gun safety
that's not what I'm faulting Donald
Trump for what I'm faulting him for is
trying to use this to first of all brag
about things for which he really
deserves no credit and secondly
confusion it's total confusion as to
what he believes the solutions are to
the problem that were faced with number
one he mentions Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer even Jeff Flake said Chuck
Schumer was one of many people involved
in the passage of that visa program Jeff
Flake also said back in 2013 we had a
bipartisan proposal to do away with this
particular program that was never made
law and it's both Republicans and
Democrats that are to blame and of
course with most of Trump's statements
there's always something or a lot
missing and in this case it's that you
still vet people who come to the United
States on this particular visa program
the selection is via lottery but you're
not exempt from vetting just because
you've been selected for a possible visa
in a lottery and the the distraction
that is
I believe is working for many many
trumpets because they are tuning into
Fox News they are watching Breitbart or
reading Breitbart and watching Infowars
etc and it is a total misdirection
campaign and by the way also taking
attention away from the growing scandal
of Trump russia-related indictments but
that's another story which we will talk
about this incident absolutely horrible
and to be a hundred percent clear none
of what Donald Trump so far has either
attempted to enact or enacted via
executive order or proposed or suggested
during the campaign or as president
would actually have done anything to
prevent this particular attack it's a
different conversation when we should be
having but it's a different conversation
than the one that Donald Trump wants to
have let's talk about Jeff Sessions
where to start right Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General jeff Sessions is
already possibly someone who perjured
himself lying under oath during his
confirmation hearings about Russia
related questions but as we've talked
about before provable perjury that's
pretty difficult in the midst of all of
the reporting though earlier this week
about the indictments of Trump
associates Paul Manafort and Rick gates
we learned about the indictment and
guilty plea of former Trump policy
adviser George papadopolis new
information has surfaced about Donald
Trump's attorney general Jeff Sessions
and we now must wonder is Jeff Sessions
in danger of being indicted himself
which of course would be nothing short
of I mean what's the word monumental if
a sitting attorney general were to be
indicted by a special counsel so first
of all what did the Papadopoulos
documents reveal about attorney general
Jeff Sessions well number one Jeff
Sessions has said multiple times that he
knew nothing about anything related to
Russia Russian collusion nothing at all
we learned from the Papadopoulos
documents from the plea agreement of
george papadapolis that Jeff Sessions
was in a meeting with Donald Trump and
Papadopoulos on March 31st of 2016 at
the time Jeff Sessions was Donald
Trump's top foreign policy advisor I
don't know what term you want to apply
to that was he the acting top foreign
policy adviser was he the temporary
the de facto top Trump foreign policy
advisor I don't know call it what you
want that's what he was at the time this
is the meeting where George papadopolis
said that he had connections that he
could help arrange a meeting between
then candidate Trump and President Putin
now whether the meeting happened or not
is not the issue here the issue is that
this hurts the credibility and the
plausibility of what we've heard from
Jeff Sessions and Donald Trump and Trump
jr. and the whole bunch of them because
this was a month before the now-infamous
Trump Tower meeting with the Russian
lawyer which means that the entire cast
of characters was aware of the Russia
stuff long before the meeting with the
Russian lawyer took place and that
meeting was not this isolated thing that
nobody knew anything about but it was
part of the bigger picture and part of
that bigger picture is a meeting where
Papadopoulos said hey I can facilitate
this I've got contacts and Trump was
there and Jeff Sessions was there but
the key part is that sessions his
comments about Russia came in sworn
testimony so far neither Trump junior to
our knowledge nor Donald Trump have made
potentially false statements about
Russia related stuff under sworn in
sworn testimony Jeff Sessions was giving
sworn testimony to the Senate during his
confirmation process when he said these
things so already the George papadopolis
plea deal puts in question even more of
Jeff Sessions comments that have already
been made but this is clearly not just
some mere speculation about sessions
right because right after this
indictment after we learned of this
indictment Jeff Sessions was brought to
a closed-door meeting at the White House
with Donald Trump just this past Monday
now presumably this would be to discuss
the strategy for suppressing the Robert
Moeller investigation but there is no
doubt that Jeff Sessions is at least
possibly on the chopping block here and
if it happens it couldn't happen to a
nicer guy right just kidding I don't
know why everybody always says that
couldn't happen to a nicer guy often it
happens to really bad people indictment
lists and we don't know about that right
what's becoming more and more clear is
that Jeff sessions is just one of many
Trump associates who has denied
knowledge has denied involvement has
denied awareness of anything
russia-related and the Papadopoulos plea
has exposed that they did have awareness
they did have involvement at least to
the extent of being in these meetings
and Donald Trump might get his wish
right Donald Trump previously said that
if he had known Jeff Sessions was going
to recuse himself on the Russia stuff he
would have hired someone else to be
attorney general if sessions gets
indicted Donald Trump might get that
opportunity that's the upside to the
possible indictment of Jeff Sessions
what do you think am i onto something or
way off I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll
take a break send me your thoughts the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Margaret Hodgkins Margaret thank you
thank you so much for signing up at
david pakman.com slash membership
mentioned yesterday that david pakman
shows Amazon affiliate link has been
totally shut down seven years of people
who had that link bookmarked evaporated
overnight so we do need your support
membership is one option david
pakman.com slash membership patreon the
other option patreon.com slash david
pakman show both give you access to the
bonus show and the full commercial free
audio and video feeds every day we do
have a new amazon link please don't
bookmark it it's it remains david
pakman.com slash amazon with a new
redirect don't bookmark it use it but
again with seven years of people's
bookmarks outdated now it's not good
it's not good at all so that is
something that we are going to have to
contend with over the coming months
let's get to hate reott mail if you
don't know about hatred mail here's what
hatred mail is because the government
that is supposedly totally annette is
the same government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom alright I don't really
understand this week's hatred mail but
there's been a bit of a break from
blatant homophobia it's been sort of
subtle homophobia in recent hatred mail
and this one we're going back to
full-fledged homophobia let's see if we
can understand what this hatreds talking
about
so Pakman were you sexing men in the
home decors section at Walmart before
you promoted yourself to host this
trainwreck of a straight face Joe in the
bowels of YouTube or were you receiving
electroshock therapy at street camp
hmm I've heard of Alex Jones but not
David Pakman don't associate with Kuck
like Pakman Hackman is a Rachel Maddow
wanna be fake progressive Zionist scum
wait so am i a fake Zionist or a real
one it's not totally clear from this one
but anyway yeah back to the full-fledged
homophobia why is it that that is such a
focus of hatred mail I don't know a lot
of questions about that and remember
that you can use hey treat male 2 turn
hate into love by using the coupon code
hey treat for tea hey treat 40 is a
coupon code that'll save you 40% off of
your membership at david pakman.com
slash membership okay big news the david
pakman show is now fully fully accepting
cryptocurrency Bitcoin aetherium and
litecoin and the background of this has
been we've had hundreds of people over
the last couple of years say hey David
I've got a bunch of Bitcoin I'm one of
these Bitcoin millionaires that put in a
hundred bucks into Bitcoin at the
beginning and now it's worth a ton
I'd love to contribute but I want to
contribute via Bitcoin and that is now
available to you
we had YouTube's ad pocalypse which
crushed our revenue at the beginning of
April I announced yesterday that our
Amazon affiliate link has been
completely and totally shut down by
Amazon and that is another notch out of
our regular revenue so we have finally
done it we can now accept Bitcoin
aetherium and light
coin I'm gonna put up our addresses on
the screen for both bitkha for all three
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin but I
understand that particularly with long
case-sensitive strings Pat is trying to
memorize these just as a goof like he
used to like to memorize pi and he's now
trying to memorize our Bitcoin address
but you don't have to do that okay we
are now we've set up a page at david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency
which has all three of our
cryptocurrency addresses that you can
copy and then paste and use those to
send cryptocurrency contributions and
we're also adding our Bitcoin aetherium
and litecoin addresses to the video
descriptions of every single youtube
video going forward and i'm gonna try to
also get it added to all of our prior
videos so this is a new opportunity if
you've got cryptocurrency and you like
contributing in that way if you like the
privacy aspect of that also this is a
good option for you and you can get all
three of our addresses at david
pakman.com slash crypto currency and
that's CR why pto currency we've already
received yesterday i just mentioned this
very off handedly and we received three
contributions one via litecoin and to be
a bitcoin so check that out david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency tell
your friends tell your family tell
anybody who will listen ok why can't
anything just go well for Donald Trump
why can't Donald Trump get through any
social situation or encounter without
completely embarrassing himself and
showing himself to be completely and
utterly out of touch and I'm talking of
course not of Donald Trump's latest
sexual encounter with his wife which I'm
sure was incredibly awkward but that's
not what I'm talking about today I'm
talking about Donald Trump's Halloween
Donald Trump welcomed the kids of the
White House I guess it's the White House
press corps I don't know if it's the
traveling press or the press that is
stationed at the White House but some
subsection of the White House and
presidential covering press and producer
Noah Ferguson apprised me to this and it
is just amazing no we're gonna play some
clips believe me folks no awareness of
his surroundings no realization that
these are kids they
happen to be the kids of press people
but that doesn't mean they know all
about the lying fake news media and all
of these other terms that Donald Trump
has been using now for over a year
these are children and Donald Trump
seems to not only have no awareness of
that and of how to talk to kids I
imagine that his conversations with
Barron Trump must be bizarre but he also
gets absolutely no basic pop cultural
references here's Donald Trump speaking
to a kid who's dressed as Darth Vader
Darth Vader's the costume of course
Darth Vader the bad guy from Star Wars
and it is the father of Luke Skywalker
right or is that he is the father of
Luke Skywalker yes he's the father of
Luke Skywalker etc etc and Donald Trump
has no clue who Darth Vader is take a
look at this and we're gonna take the
picture in the Oval Office okay yeah Wow
who are you Darth Vader wow that's
incredible reminds me of when Mitt
Romney couldn't identify a chocolate
doughnut maybe the most out of touch
moment of the entire bromley
presidential campaign reminder if you
missed that that's a doughnut mitt have
you ever heard of that
then Trump goes into bad-mouthing the
parents of the kids which is a nice
touch because again these were the kids
of media people but most of these kids
don't know that Trump's been
bad-mouthing their parents for so long
and Trump starts bad-mouthing the
parents to the kids yeah and then Trump
makes a girl cry and then it comes up
this is this is probably the weirdest
this is probably the weirdest clip of
the entire thing Trump makes a girl cry
and then it comes out that the girls
Japanese and then it gets really weird
where Trump seems to grimace after
acknowledging that the girl is Japanese
and maybe the weirdest interaction
between a president an
that we've ever seen do you know they
are do you know who they are the
friendly medium you know these beautiful
wonderful children the grimace on his
face after the girl says I know you're
going to Japan is like nothing I've seen
before and then Trump decides which kids
are thin enough to have candy telling
one girl that guy I think it's a girl
that cheap because she doesn't have
weight problems she said she's allowed
to have candy in the white house Jade
take a look at this man then Trump makes
a weird political comment to a kid and
then congratulate the room for what
isn't immediately clear take a look
congratulations folks nobody gets it not
a single kid in the room knows what the
hell Trump is talking about you're
treated well by the press and then we
finally understand what it is that Trump
is congratulating the room for he's
congratulating the parents I guess for
being able to have produced these
children anyway well congratulations
folks you did a good job yeah I wouldn't
say you did very well here but really
just everything is so cringeworthy ly
awkward it reminds me of when Trump
welcomed people to the Easter Egg Roll
so the Easter Egg Roll is this
non-political longtime White House
tradition kids get to a search for
Easter they roll these
to regs and I think there's also an
Easter egg hunt on the White House lawn
it's not political it's just fun it's
mostly for the kids and Trump gives a
political speech and if you're not
watching this one you're gonna miss half
of the optics because Donald Donald
Trump gives a political speech with the
Easter Bunny standing next to him take a
look at this and we will be stronger and
bigger and better as a nation than ever
before we're right on track you see
what's happening and we are right on
track so thank you everybody for being
yeah
next to the Easter Bunny and giving a
political speech you might as well have
Batman standing behind you when you
announced the next action against North
Korea what a bizarre bizarre event at
the White House yesterday and he just
can't be a normal person because he's
not he's he's so much more out of touch
even than Mitt Romney and I know you
know Mitt Romney had this amazing staged
event where he he went shopping at
Costco and all he bought was multiple
cases of seltzer water and Greek yogurt
like it was during the campaign against
Barack Obama it was such an obviously
fabricated moment where Mitt Romney
grabbed the shopping card and he just
filled it with just why did why do have
so much seltzer you're traveling were
you even going to bring the souther
you're flying around everywhere you're
bringing huge cases of Seltzer
everywhere you go didn't make any sense
Trump similar thing is like when he eats
Kentucky Fried Chicken or when he used
to on Trump's on Trump on an air Trump
on Trump's plane but that wasn't even
staged
that's real Trump doesn't know a healthy
meal he wouldn't know a healthy meal if
it forced itself down his throat but
that's his only connection to sort of
like average middle-class consumer
culture of the United staes just
completely unable to act like a normal
person because he's not and by the way
we know he's a germaphobe we have to
assume that right after the kids left
his desk was sanitized twice I mean
candy and kids touching your desk I
don't think that's gonna fly for a
germophobe like Trump bizarre and people
are now ready to discuss
or noticed it you can join the
discussion there at david packing.com
slash re v d itback applicants the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm joined today by Graham Allison who's
the Douglas Dylan professor of
government at the Harvard Kennedy School
of Government our topic today is China
professor you know I read a lot in sort
of popular media about when will if
China will become the world's superpower
but there's a sort of other approach to
that which is that by some measures one
could argue China is already the
superpower can you talk a little bit
about that and how we might evaluate
such a claim well it's a great question
Americans all know in our bones that we
are number one
so it's a very yet almost inconceivable
for most of us that some other power
should rival us or even surpass us in
many domains in fact in the book that
I've this recently published called
destined for work and the US and Janet
escape through Sydney's trap I give two
tables that I present to my students at
Harvard in my class in the first one
which says when could China become
number one and in my class I have 26
indicators in the book I just have a
condensed version so one could try to
become the largest middle class the
largest number of billionaires the
largest producer of computers the
fastest supercomputers the larger the
the event the most advanced artificial
intelligence the largest economy in the
world
so students guess 2030 2040 not in my
lifetime then I make him look at a
second chart the the heading of which is
already already all those things have
happened the China already has the
largest middle class bigger than their
whole American population China already
has the most billionaires China already
is the largest producer of computers
China already wins the contest for the
fastest supercomputer China is already
the largest economy in the world
measured by what both the IMF and the
CIA regard as the single best yardstick
for comparing national economies which
is purchasing power parity that was the
big take away from the IMF World Bank
meeting in Washington in 2014 but most
of us miss it
very good so in hearing you say this
some in our audience might say wow I
must really be not just so just very
unaware of all of the data that points
to China being the superpower in the
world right now there's also the
possibility that there's something that
is not maybe measurable in some of those
statistics that we might be able to
flesh out that might tell us more about
the concept of a superpower so just as
like one example and I'm really curious
to hear your thoughts on it there is the
argument that some make which is that
looking at the size of China's economy
or even purchasing power parity and some
other economic indicators it doesn't
consider for example China's relatively
undeveloped financial sector and that
consumption of goods because you have a
huge population and manufacturing
capacity is one thing but that the
superpower dumb for lack of a better
term also relates to the influence of a
country's financial sector
geopolitically what about something like
that or those critiques valid in your
mind
I would say yes that the I would not not
argue that China has surpassed the u.s.
in every dimension for example military
balance where I would say we continue to
have in some domains ten yearly than
some domains maybe even a 20-year lead
in the financial arena another very
interesting question in case now Chinese
would say well yes the u.s. is the
center of international finance and the
US has liberalized open financial
liberalization financial system and
that's actually been the recurring cause
of collapses like the collapse of 2008
2009 which was actually you know started
Wall Street that we Chinese they would
say are not going to liberalize Eric our
finance we maintain more state control
of it in order to push it ourselves I
get such consequences and in fact I mean
if you look and see what happened in
2009 and 2009 the US economy declined as
a result of the Great Recession and
China did not so there's a little bit
there the US with the American dollar as
the international currency has a great
advantage internationally as the
currency of last resort so people like
countries like China all the trillion
and a half dollars of American paper so
basically we take paper we put a stamp
on it and people take it as if it was as
good as gold well that's because we're
the reserve currency that gives us
another significant advantage over time
will China hope and as it we're seeking
to have its currency the RMB become a
second or third currency and even then a
rival currency that's that's over time
so I would say them and and similarly in
per capita income another measure so the
Chinese have a good economy the total
economy of which is bigger than ours but
they have four times as many people so
that means people that are 1/4 the per
capita GDP so per capita GDP again is
another measure relevant for some
purposes so if I were making as I do in
my course I would say there's no single
metric for measuring on nations they
compete in many many different
dimensions but we should notice that in
many relevant dimensions where Americans
would believe that we were number one
because we've always been number one in
our memory and lifetime we now have a
serious rival yeah and I think that
you're getting at something which is
sort of what I want to talk about next
which is the characteristics that
portray geopolitical power seem to be
different than some of these internal
metrics that you cited I mean can you
talk a little bit about when we think
about geopolitical
power what metrics might we look at
there or are they more qualitative
rather than quantitative well extremely
good questions so again and if I were
exploring it in my class it would take a
whole a whole quest but let me try to
just do the top of a few icebergs here
so basically economics is the
substructure for power in international
politics if a country is bigger and
stronger than another that doesn't mean
that will necessarily be more powerful
in every dimension but as Damon Runyon
would say that was the that's the way to
bet it so as China has become the
biggest economy it's also become the
biggest importer and the biggest
exporter so if you look for example
around the South China Sea at the
countries that are organized at a unit
called ASEAN so this would be Thailand
the Philippines Malaysia Indonesia
Singapore these countries now find
themselves attached to the gravity in
effect of a larger Chinese economy which
is their number one trading partner as a
consequence particularly because China
plays hardball in geo-economics
it squeezes them when it doesn't like
though something that they're doing to
the point that they comply so this is a
play case where even though it's not
just the raw comparison if if you're my
number one market and you're prepared to
close your market for me for example if
I'm the Philippines and I sell you
bananas and you'll just let them sit
there on the dock and rot until the
point that I give in to you
Lord the whole I become more compliant
so that's on that space on the other
hand if you ask where there's Chinese
students want to go study they want to
go study more that if they have an
opportunity in the US as do students
from all over the rest of the world does
that provide a significant advantage for
the u.s. in the sense that then people
come here they see what a free society
is they see our society in
many of the things that they like about
it they also see some of the ugly parts
of our society but still in a democratic
society like ours at least when we're
working as as we should do we find our
mistakes we try to correct the mistakes
we were perfectly prepared to debate the
mistakes so I think that in general if
you offer people a chance to be more
free or less free what I like to have
somebody else telling me which whether I
can go to Google and what sites I can go
to and whether I can read this or that
no I wouldn't but in China they manage
to control the information or tried
their best to control information
accessible to people so I think there's
many this is a very complex calculation
as you try to think about all of the
dimensions of power and influence do you
have any feelings one way or the other
as to how if at all the perception or
reality and pick either or both to
address of the United States as a world
superpower has shifted during the nine
months of the current administration
well I think the good question I think
that the first point is to put this in
context so long before Donald Trump
arrived in Washington Washington was
regarded as dysfunctional we should
remember that the Congress has not been
able to pass a budget you know for nine
years
so this functionality is not new to
Washington Donald Trump in to some
extent and his administration is a
expression of a political system it's
not working very well but the
combination of the two
lead people in other countries for
example China which is just at its bigg
19th Party Congress one of the things
they say that Chinese is looking look at
the US and see the way it governs itself
or fails to do so and ask would you
rather not have a competent group of
people running the railroad and I would
say that's a good argument actually for
the first time ever this was interesting
at the party Congress last week Chinese
had been very reserved about holding out
the
their form of leadership in the society
and governance which is basically a
party led meal authoritarian structure
in which the citizens and everybody
else's rights are confined and
constrained and guided and led by the
party well that's not our system and
they said you generally have been really
reserved about saying well we don't we
don't have they would say we don't have
a model we just try to govern ourselves
we're a developing country this first
time in GCN brings work plan this big
plan that he laid out last week he says
actually the Chinese model may appeal to
many countries we're trying to get
wealthier the way we have done so look
and see what we've done in terms of our
development and compare this with what
other societies that have been trying to
govern themselves more according to
American principles have done so I would
say that's a that's an element of the of
the answer to your question we've been
speaking with Professor Graham Allison
the Douglas Dylan professor of
government at the Harvard Kennedy School
of Government up the road from us
professor thanks so much for talking to
us
thank you so much for having me the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I think you're gonna like this one this
is really funny remember Monday when I
played a clip of Corey Lewandowski
Trump's former a campaign manager he
went on Fox News and he was on to
provide reaction to the indictments then
we didn't know who it was but we knew
the indictments were coming of Paul
Manafort and Rick gates and we learned
also of the indictment and guilty plea
of George papadopolis and Corey
Lewandowski said you know what we really
need to be talking about
is the Clinton administration just as a
reminder here's Corey Lewandowski we
played this clip for you earlier in the
week oh the White House your reaction to
that
the dam is breaking it said we will
never gonna hold the water back ever
give me a break okay look the
speculation is so insane right now what
we should be focusing on other continued
lies of the Clinton administration to
continue fallacies that they perpetuate
look Robert Miller is doing his job
whatever that entails and he has now
filed charges against somebody that we
don't know what they are we don't know
who they were against so when I saw that
I thought is he talking about the actual
only Clinton administration that has
existed which is Bill Clinton's
administration if so he says that the
focus right now should be events that
allegedly took place between 1992 and
the year 2000 that's weird or is he
referring to some non-existent Hillary
Clinton administration I don't know but
the list is growing the list is growing
of these unhinged right-wingers who
continue to talk about the Hillary
Clinton administration or at least
referring to something that seems like
they're talking about Hillary Clinton in
the wake of Trump campaign indictments
here's Corey Lewandowski again talking
about the Clinton administration this
time he actually does correct himself we
know that the members of the sophia's
Committee the Committee on foreign
investment in the u.s. of the members
who were sitting on that committee I
think seven or nine of them were tied to
the Clinton administration I'm sorry the
Clinton Foundation this generally angry
demeanor from Corey Lewandowski he's
always angry during these interviews it
doesn't work for him i people some
people in the audience know that
economist Richard Wolff was a professor
of mine at the University of
Massachusetts and he would when talking
about some of the failings of our
economic system he would take on sort of
an angry tone during his lectures but it
actually felt natural like it fit the
situation and it felt natural and Anna
santak this constant clearly fabricated
anger from corey lewandowski really
doesn't work and it also doesn't make
what he's saying logical at all and here
is Sean Hannity Sean Hannity also
referring to President Clinton but
talking about Hillary bumbling and then
I guess kind of correcting himself no
Trump collusion here's what we do have
tonight this is what the media will
ignore this is what matters these are
the facts this is where the evidence
comes in what did hit what did President
Clinton or President Clinton wanna be
President Obama and administration
what did they know about the uranium one
scandal that's the real story the
uranium one story from President Hillary
Clinton oops did I say president Hillary
Clinton again that's not what I meant I
meant wanna be President Hillary Clinton
and Hillary joked about this and
whenever Hillary Clinton jokes about
something it makes her 1% more likable
she said Fox is peddling these stories
about me it appears they don't know I'm
not president and that's there's two
views on this right one is they are just
miss speaking these are verbal gaffes
verbal typos the other view is that and
I just gave you a couple of examples but
there's many more that this is
deliberate gaslighting right using the
term president Hillary Clinton using the
term the Clinton administration to
confuse the term to make it confusing
for the audience to even know who it is
that they're talking about and generally
to sow seeds of distraction from the
major issues and of course the major
issues are the multiple indictments
against the sitting president's campaign
staff that is actually the big news not
the uranium one story and I got an email
from a viewer with what is kind of a
darker hypothesis saying that referring
to the Hillary Clinton administration in
this way and referencing President
Clinton when talking about Hillary is a
sort of dog whistle to a shadow
presidential administration that Hillary
Clinton is or was at some point running
the show and my immediate reaction to
that was hold on a second
even trumpets aren't so stupid that they
would fall for that and then I
remembered wait a second they elected
Donald
maybe they would fall for that and
they're doing the exact same thing with
collusion right they go back and forth
between there was no collusion with
Russia to collusion wouldn't be illegal
to collusion doesn't have a legal
meaning to Hillary actually colluded for
uranium but collusion is not illegal
anyway so what do we really mean it is
probably a combination of incompetence
combined with trying to sow confusion
and spread misinformation 2016 was the
hottest year on record and 2016 saw
faster than ever increases in carbon
dioxide co2 in the atmosphere we now
have the greenhouse gas bulletin for
2016 it's a yearly report from the World
Meteorological Organization and it
debunks the common talking point which
is hey we can't possibly evaluate
long-term climate trends because we only
have temperature data for the last 120
or so or so years the counterpoint is we
can use science to determine co2 in the
atmosphere for the last 800,000 years
and in 2016 the levels of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere reached their highest
point in 800,000 years and a significant
portion of that increase has happened in
just the last 70 years now I don't
necessarily want to just talk about the
science here what I'm more interested in
is CNN's coverage of climate science CNN
did a report about the study I just
mentioned to you 2016 hottest year on
record 2016 most carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere in the last 800 years and in
that report
CNN simply did not consider the
possibility that climate change isn't
happening they didn't even cite the
points of view of climate science
deniers they sometimes call themselves
climate sceptics or climate realists
they have all sorts of names for
themselves I think that it spot number
one it's possible this is something CNN
did just in this one report and they're
gonna go back to giving a voice to the
climate science deniers in other
segments but that's actually a big deal
because there is this ongoing discussion
as to how significantly should such a
minority opinion be represented if we
have a 90
seven two three imbalance in scientists
climate scientists who believe humans
are impacting the climate and those who
believe humans are not impacting the
client right if the RIT climate if the
ratio is ninety seven to three among the
scientists how much air time should the
climate science deniers be given in the
media should it be three percent of the
time
should it be fifty fifty as we so often
see the science deniers will say well
listen CNN is biased fake news because
they're not reporting on the other side
CNN may have decided and if they did the
scientists that decide this it's the
right decision and they correctly
decided that there is no legitimate
other side worth mentioning anymore and
if you look at comments online the
deniers are saying this is political
fear-mongering it's fear-mongering to
say 2016 is the hottest year on record
2016 had the most co2 in the atmosphere
in 800,000 years it's not political
fear-mongering it's that the scientists
are scared it's not liberals trying to
scare you the data is objectively scary
and scientists are telling us that and
by the way how is 2017 looking in terms
of temperatures for all the years we
have on record not good as of two years
ago twenty seven I'm sorry as of two
weeks ago twenty seventeen was the
second hottest year on record we've
basically had no fall in Boston it's
almost we're close to winter at this
point we're close to when we sometimes
start getting snow in Boston and really
cold temperatures and up until even this
week we had temperatures of 70 degrees
so something is clearly very wrong and
more than likely depending on what
happens in the last two months of this
year 2017 will be either the second or
third heart hottest year ever but hey
nothing to see here we're gonna
reinvigorate the coal industry says our
current administration how is this
deliberate blindness to what's going on
going to be viewed by future generations
if they're even around to actually
discuss it and I would reference
yesterday's bonus show story about how
we don't have to
wait for some point in the future to
start being able to identify deaths
happening as a result of climate change
in what we're doing to the planet it's
happening now it's happening now and we
talked about it on yesterday's bonus
show hey I've got a voicemail number and
you can call this number anytime you
want the numbers two one nine two david
p a troll called in well someone i
identified as a troll called in to say
they are mostly not a troll but they are
sometimes a troll take a listen to this
hey David um I just watched you answer
my question on the estate tax and I want
to say thank you for answering it it was
a very thorough answer but I just wanted
to say usually I'm not calling into your
show trolling I have less maybe three or
four trolls before because I thought it
was funny but usually when I call in it
is not a troll I have genuine answers
and I just want to say i watch your show
every single day I'm on your reddit all
the time as well thanks I love your
program I love the community that you've
built when I call in and troll it's
typically just good fun
and I just I don't know I did it just
kind of makes me laugh sometimes oh so
I'll stop doing that okay but usually
when I call in it is genuine questions
so thank you for answering my question
about the estate tax very very good no
my pleasure absolutely and it's good to
know that this is only sometimes a troll
so I was completely wrong in saying that
this is always a troll
it is only sometimes a troll because
they think it's funny very very good on
today's bonus show a Japanese company is
giving their non-smoking employees six
extra days of vacation to compensate for
all of the five to ten minutes cigarette
breaks that the cigarette smokers get
what do we think about that is it some
form of discrimination we will talk
about it on the bonus show we also are
going to talk about a new report that
indicates that how your brain responds
to certain particular words might
predict your risk for suicide and the
FDA is warning candy lovers too much
black licorice could land you in the
hospital is Pat throwing out his two
tons of black licorice that he just
bought he will tell us on the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership is one
way to get access to the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show is
another way and remember the david
pakman show now accepting cryptocurrency
contributions david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency
for more information on
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you